-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
Former President Trump
on Saturday said
that the 2020 election
should be overturned
and the Constitution
should be terminated.
Well, I'll say this for him --
he does give a memorable wedding
toast.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is
the Georgia Senate runoff,
and unfortunately
Herschel Walker's vote
isn't going to count.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said on Friday
the Democrats must win
the Georgia Senate runoff
to avoid
a 50-50 split
in the chamber.
"But that would mean the end
of my presidency,"
said Joe Manchin.
[ Laughter ]
After she was kicked off
a Spirit airlines flight,
former New Jersey governor
Chris Christie's niece,
Shannon Epstein,
reportedly injured six deputies
while resisting arrest,
including kicking an officer
in the groin, which can only
mean one thing.
She's running.
[ Laughter ]
During last night's reception
at the White House
for Kennedy Center honorees,
President Biden praised
the band U2 and said their music
has "changed the world."
Damn, I knew Biden was old, but
I didn't know he was that old.
[ Laughter ]
New York City recently posted
a job listing
for a Director of
Rodent Mitigation,
which will pay up to
$170,000 a year.
Wow, $170,000 a year to say,
"Maybe don't serve dinner
in the gutter."
[ Laughter ]
Might that mitigate?
According to the latest numbers,
crime on New York's subway
last month decreased by 13%
because it's hard to commit
a crime if you can't move
your arms.
[ Laughter ]
Rapper Bad Bunny was named
Spotify's most streamed artist
worldwide in 2022.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No word yet on what he's doing
with his $6.
[ Laughter ]
A tortoise named Jonathan
that lives on the island of
St. Helena recently celebrated
his 190th birthday with
his 140-year-old trophy wife.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's laughing at you,
Jonathan!
And finally, amid the chaotic
pre-sale for Taylor Swift's
The Eras tour, more than
two dozen fans recently filed
a lawsuit against Ticketmaster's
parent company, Live Nation,
for unlawful conduct.
And while a trial is still
a long ways off,
pre-sale tickets
are already available.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.